[Music]
hello there june is here yet again and
it comes with a bunch of games vying for
your attention there's only a few big
hitters this time around which means
it's the chance for free to play games
to step up to fill the void we can only
begin today if you've written a terrible
dad joke in the comments below you done
it
okay we can begin
arguably the biggest game releasing in
june is the quarry a survival horror
outing which is like playing through
your own interactive movie if you've
played the sublime until dawn in 2015 or
the less impressive dark pictures
anthology over the last year or two
you'll know exactly what to expect from
supermassive games and their next punt
wettingly scary outing the quarry tasks
us with controlling nine teenagers who
must survive their final night as camp
councillors at hackett's quarry each
decision we make changes the scenario
and branches the gameplay in unknown
ways and affects all the other
characters we are told all nine of the
campers have around 12 different ways to
meet their end we're also told we should
be trying to get them through this alive
but what's the fun in that if you like
80s cheesy horror flicks the quarry is
the perfect game for you if you do have
the guts to play it look out for the
quarry on june 10th on ps4 ps5 all the
xboxes and pc oh and coming a little
later on july 8th is an online
multiplayer mode which lets everyone
vote to see what happens next perfect if
you're terrible at making decisions
at the other end of the spectrum is
sonic origins after the amazing success
of sonic mania and the recent sonic the
hedgehog movies we now have origins
effectively a remaster of the first four
sonic titles from 1991 to 1994. sega see
this new audience brought in by the
movies and thought hey let's sell them
all the games all over again origins is
a 2d side-scrolling platformer and has
the usual upgrades you see when 90s
games are re-released including an
increased frame count which really helps
during frantic scenes and an engine
tweak it's actually running on the retro
engine used for sonic mania additional
animations have been created just for
this game and there's even the og 4x3
aspect ratio for people who were alive
before widescreen tvs the classic mode
also has the same difficulty level as
back in the 1990s so if you'd like to
relive the days when sonic was a legit
threat to nintendo and mario then grab
origins on june 23rd on playstation xbox
pc and switch
okay let's go through some free stuff
free games that need you to stay alive
let's start with one which is going free
on june the 1st knockout city remember
talking about this one before we spoke
about this about a year ago and i did
say the game would die without a
free-to-play audience and now it's
finally here this may be too little too
late
knockout city is dodgeball the game
running around on the streets and the
rooftops trying to smash a rubber ball
into other players of course there's
more to it than that with moves to
master and a reliance on timing dodging
and catching the ball are key skills
like you'd expect but if you lack
ability just like me you can get brutal
instead i mean it get physical different
inputs affect the ball differently like
a moon ball which lets us jump higher
and bomb ball which explodes and if you
cannot find a ball become it and let a
teammate throw you instead customization
is the draw to keep playing with battle
pass style incentives after being on ps
plus and game pass this is knockout
city's final chance to survive
so if you don't want knockout city to be
yet another dead game join the first on
pretty much every platform switch
playstations xboxes and the pc
[Music]
now we have a free game which is already
out roller champions released on may
25th another extreme sports game with a
weaponized ball roller champions has a
very simple premise grab a ball throw it
through a hoop simple right one of the
big plus points about roller champions
is all about aggression when you do not
have the ball you can hurt the
opposition any way you can to make them
drop the ball it's a full contact spot
there's a really cool risk reward
element of roller champions every
successful lap of the course your team
completes while holding the ball means
the next goal will be worth an
additional point so do you continue
lapping to win big or do you bank your
shot and get the points on the board as
quick as possible this also means one
play can bring you back into a game
regardless of scoreline there's
something about this which is quite
addicting and just like knockout city
customization is the appeal right now
there are limited edition skins to
unlock for playing during the first few
days or weeks since we last spoke about
this a practice mode has been added to
the game so you can get a little bit
better before you're thrown in at the
deep end roller champions is out right
now on playstation xbox and pc
[Music]
and now another free game which began
life as a full price title four guys
remember this when it released during
lockdown what a game it was and on june
21st it's going free to play and on a
ton of platforms playstation xbox switch
and pc all for free all with full
cross-play support if you've been living
under a rock fall guys is a battle
royale mixed with a tv show like total
wipeout each level more contestants are
left behind because there can be only
one winner the rounds are a mixture of
solo and team-based mini-games from
avoiding climbing slime to catching a
penguin they are so random you may have
moved on from this title but with xbox
and switch joining the party it's a
great time to go back to it june 21st
also sees the next gen versions of fall
guy's release 2 a dedicated ps5 version
is confirmed fall guys is now owned and
backed by fortnite demigods epic games
who have already showed us a new
creative mode is coming which will let
us build our own courses and play them
with friends the battle passes are
confirmed to remain allowing us to
unlock new cosmetics but these will have
two different versions now a free tier
like the good old days and a new premium
tier if you're og by the way you will
get the first one totally free new
courses have been added regularly and
more are coming when this goes free to
play on june 21st i think i'm gonna go
back
[Music]
okay that's the big games and the free
games out of the way but here are some
other premium games you may have missed
check out madison four years ago a demo
released which scared the pants off us a
first person horror game inspired by the
sublime silent hills that game never
made it to a final release but at last
madison has on june 24th we'll be living
through some hardcore psychological
drama being so scared we can't turn
around for fear of what could be waiting
for us we wake up locked in a room and
must perform a ritual to progress with
intense puzzles to solve and the
constant threat of the unknown madison
could be a huge horror title but if
you're scared like me we can watch
markiplier play instead madison releases
on june 24th on ps4 ps5 the xbox's pc
and not even the switch players can
escape this one madison is on switch
there you try it
[Music]
here's another really interesting game
an indie game it's called silt you wake
up on the ocean floor with no idea
what's going on you swim around the
silhouetted world solving puzzles trying
to understand why you are here we have
the ability to possess fish and other
sea creatures to navigate through the
world silt echoes the monosyllabic
worlds of games like outside and limbo
the desire to understand the world you
find yourself in keeps pulling you
forward even though there is no dialogue
to help interpret the information you
receive the further we press on the more
warped the abyss becomes leading to
goliaths deadly creatures like no other
stilt releases on june 1st on ps4 ps5
xbox one series snx pc and twitch if
you're a fan of 2d fighters you should
keep an eye on capcom fighting
collection 10 classic fighters from
history are all brought together into
one game street fighter may be the
headline act but many of the precursors
that made street fighter 2 the marquee
title it is are here additional content
includes puzzle fighter a game mode
which combined combat with tetris levels
of puzzle addiction fans of fighting
games will get a kick out of all the
extras including artwork and renowned
music tracks i know it's not one for
everyone but definitely this will be
appealing to fans of fighters over the
ages and there's an online multiplayer
mode which will be the place to find the
best of the best capcom fighting
collection hits you in the face on june
24th on playstation xbox pc and switch
so that's it a mixed bag of aaa indie
and a butt ton of free to play games
what you're playing this month i reckon
i'll see you all on fall guys am i right
i'm adam you're awesome be sure to leave
a dead joke and i'll see you next time